Hunter is not off the hook the first
son's sweetheart plea deal getting blown
up in a dramatic legal twist Hunter
Biden showing up in a federal courthouse
in Delaware and pleading not guilty to
gun and tax charges the shocking
development happened after the judge
started asking just some basic questions
on the terms of the original plea
agreement like what was and was not part
of the deal the judge was very concerned
on whether Hunter could get blanket
immunity from future prosecutions and at
one point said that she is not going to
be a rubber stamp the prosecutors also
admitting that there's still an ongoing
investigation surrounding Hunter Biden
and potential violations of foreign
lobbying law the White House well you
can imagine not too Keen to talk about
any of this
Hunter Biden is a private citizen and
this was a personal matter for him
as we have said the president the first
lady they love their son and they
support him as he continues to rebuild
his life
when his Senator crafted
ration as a president he talks often
about the need to get illegal Firearms
off of our streets so when someone
possesses one illegally what does the
president believe should happen to them
I'm going to be very careful because I
see where this question is going and I'm
just going to refer you as this has been
an independent investigation it's
overseen by the Department of Justice
I'm going to let them speak to this as
they are moving forward
judge there's probably a good reason
that the justice department did not
release the plea agreement for all of us
to see because when the judge started
just asking some basic questions it was
pretty clear it was outrageous they
should be embarrassed well the deal was
laughable and the Department of Justice
today is not in a good place what
normally happens in a plea deal and and
I remember from when I was a judge I
mean that the the day you took please
was a slow day there was never any drama
everybody understood the parameters of
The Plea the defendant comes in and the
judge has to do an allocution to make
sure that the defendant understands the
parameters of The Plea and so the judge
will be very specific about what did you
do what did you say what were you
thinking in this case you know on a tax
case where did the money come from who
were you working for and the tax years
that
um he's charged for but in this
particular case uh normally you would
have you know the defense and the
prosecutor would have hammered this out
I mean this would have been very clear
I've never had anything like that happen
to me ever wow never I mean plea deals
they're they're hammered out because
they know if they don't do it they end
up going to trial so in this case it was
really laughable what happened because
when the judge started the the
discussion and the the intro to the
allocution it was clear that uh when she
said what is going on with this
continuing investigation and then the
defense attorney started talking about
immunity and it appeared that they were
thinking about immunity going into the
future not just past immunity but
immunity going into the future which is
something that is just not done unless
you're at the very least cooperating and
bringing in someone like a major drug
dealer so the allocution as it was
supposed to go forward basically
couldn't happen because once it was on
the record the the Department of Justice
had to say
well it's a continuing investigation and
the judge says so you might file more
crimes more charges and they say
possibly and she says like pharah for an
agent like Paul manafort and at that
point the attorneys started getting very
uncomfortable because here's the here's
the insult Dana this was a deal where
everyone was in on the con but the judge
and the American people right it was a
con going down they didn't expect the
judge to ask any questions and they said
you know what we're going to get this
through and Hunter's going to walk out
and he's going to be just fine and the
judge was not interested in what had
gone on in terms of you know the they're
saying that you know we're going to give
them future immunity because she knew it
was continuing investigation and even if
it isn't this Department of Justice the
next Department of Justice of statute of
limitations hasn't passed can go after
him but um the the she then said to the
to the prosecutors is there any press in
the Department of Justice for doing
something like this with both the
diversion program with the gun which she
said was unheard of and I've never heard
of it it's one of the things I've talked
about how can a guy go to plead guilty
to a gun charge when he has him charged
with a gun charge
uh and they couldn't have they didn't
have any answers to any of this now this
started Dana the night last night right
before the plea there was someone who
called to strike testimony of the
whistleblowers and happened on I believe
on Tuesday or Monday of this week uh
from the transcript the judge tracked
the phone call the judge found out that
uh it was traced back to someone
connected to Hunter Biden's lawyers the
judge is the one who found that out so
when that judge walked into that
courtroom she had a bad taste in her
mouth from the beginning when they tried
to strike the testimony of the
whistleblowers and in the end of the doj
couldn't offer this deal and say with
the wink and a nod it's under
investigation and it was clear why they
were doing it to keep Congress from it
you're probably going to hear a lot
about this judge from the left I would
imagine some pretty aggressive scrutiny
you imagine is coming remember
interestingly she is the one she ruled
against the laptop repairman in his
defamation suits so it's not like she
has been somebody who is just trying to
help
um the anti-hunter side if that's if we
can call it that Greg do you remember
when the Hunter lawyers announced this
plea deal they said well we have a plea
deal and we consider this matter closed
and then the justice department said
well actually it still could be open and
then well maybe not but maybe it is and
now we know that it's not closed yeah by
the way congratulations on winning that
medal at the track meet
do you know that you say that every time
I wear it which might mean
it was
a try to trick us and they said oh this
matter is closed but it was as open as
Hunter's robe he determined you know he
he demanded blanket coverage probably
the only time he's ever demanded a
blanket uh but I'm not a lawyer although
people often mistaken me for one I think
that I always thought that you plead for
like the main big crime and then you
they forego the little ones but in this
case it seemed like it was the reverse
it was like the little ones he was only
had to deal but it was the big stuff he
got away with so I'm always I I mean I
think this is good news what's happening
because if this was you would it go
better or worse when your last name is
Biden you know not only are you afforded
exemptions from all kinds of ludicrous
Behavior even the mention of going after
missing is off limits by the Press you
can go after Trump that family but how
dare you go after the Biden family this
guy
you got a motorcade to court I mean I
mean who are they protecting them from
you know an angry pimp or the United
Federation of hookers I mean seriously I
get he's the son but come on this I just
kind of I think when you see this you
know that they're being treated
differently all the time so I think
that's why this is kind of an
interesting twist because I didn't see
this coming because I've pretty much
given up on our justice system I've
worked with this woman named Eileen
O'Connor at the justice department she
ran the tax division at Justice and she
had this headline in the Wall Street
Journal you'd go to prison for what
Hunter Biden did and maybe today Jesse
people feel like at least the judge was
willing to look at this and not just
rubber stamp it I was happy when I heard
it break Americans are happy about it we
have not had a win when it came to
Justice in a very very long time
they've been indicting Trump on a lot of
BS stuff and now we're finally starting
to feel the momentum shift and that's a
good thing we knew as the judge said
there was Shenanigans last night when
they tried to make a phony phone call an
impersonation a little dirty tricked uh
you know I'm actually the Republican
attorney can you strike this from the
record they got caught cold so the judge
is already angry going in this deal was
struck
before the IRS whistleblowers came out
right this deal was struck before the
bribe document dropped the 5 million to
the big guy
so the deal probably wasn't even papered
this might have just been a gentleman's
agreement let's not put it in writing
so A lot's changed since this deal was
done and they get out there and the
minute it was scrutinized one little bit
the whole thing collapses the justice
department said uh yeah we might have to
keep looking into this guy and then
Hunters attorney is like well then the
deal is off you know we're not supposed
to look into my guy anymore and they
tried to put it back together and they
went to Chambers they could not put this
thing back together
I Weiss the Delaware prosecutor at this
point now with impeachment on the table
oh yeah does not want to be a part of
the cover-up remember you have the crime
and then you have the covered up if this
goes to an impeachment hearing they're
going to look into obstruction of
justice yes and if the Delaware
prosecutor is in on the obstruction
that's going to be a problem so he tried
to get a little distance from this thing
and the judge is right
the judge comes out with this gun charge
it's a felony gun charge and it's just
expunged for nothing she's like this has
never happened before and you're not
giving me any discretion once you sign
this deal I can't even
decide whether I like it or not it's a
done deal so she said get this garbage
out of here a lot can happen between now
and September 1st when they have to
actually come up with a new agreement
you have Devin Archer testifying on
Monday the guys are the inside man he
could sink it and then you have bank
records coming out later in the week
with Comer so this thing is only going
to get worse for Hunter Biden and that
means it gets worse for Joe Budden
speaking of Joe Biden just take a listen
to him ignoring questions today about
that
Mr President McCarthy says
oh sad do you remember Harold the White
House at the time that with this plea
announcement was made they said okay
it's closed we're all done here and they
basically were like we're not ever
having to talk about this again and that
is not what's happening heading into a
pretty tough election good to be back
around the table oh yes welcome back say
a couple things first I think the
process worked uh for those who may say
that our process is broken in the
country and we have two standards this
was an example of there not being two
standards uh what judges write when you
have a plea deal you often the judge is
often asking these questions to protect
the defendant because if the defendant
is entering a guilty plea he or she
needs to be afforded the right to say
that before the court before the judge
so these questions basic questions were
asked what is inexplicable to me is how
the agreement between or the mutual
understanding between the prosecution
and the defense was not there the
defense believed that he would get
immunity for everything going forward
even unrelated to the tax stuff and the
gun stuff I thought there would be
immunity for the tax and the gun stuff
but I I hard to believe it they thought
there would be immunity going forward
unless they had already agreed to that
too we learned from this there's an
investigation continue a continued
investigation underway in the Hunter and
some of his business dealings and three
um I go back to at the start because I
am relieved that the process worked I'm
relieved that the judge asked these
questions and I am relieved that
Americans everyday Americans are
starting to understand how our process
works we shouldn't have cameras I saw
someone maybe on our Network alerts and
wish there were cameras and audio in the
courtroom I don't but I do I I am
relieved and and frankly gratified that
the court asked these questions and
inexplicable to me is how the
prosecution defense were not on the same
page going in and we'll have to see
where this goes they were but they
couldn't admit it well I don't well
that's kind of that was that was I think
what was so are you not embarrassed well
because that's that's common what is
clear is we don't know the answer that
but we know this the judge asked the
right questions today and it seems like
the outcome the right outcome was what
happened there was no precedent okay
this was out of the ordinary and hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else